my life is fueled by my being and the
being fuels to doing so I come from a
centered place I come from a focused
place I come from compassion it's just
my nature I come from a willingness to
understand and to be understood and I
come from wanting to connect I mean the
secret of that show for 25 years is that
people could see themselves in me all
over the world they could see themselves
in me
and even as I became more and more
financially successful which was a big
surprise to me I was like oh wow so what
I realized is through the whole process
because I'm grounded in my own self that
although I could have more shoes my feet
stayed on the ground although I was
wearing better shoes I could understand
that it really was because I was
grounded I was doing and continue to
this day to do the consciousness work I
work at staying awake dear beautiful
brown skinned girl
and I use the word beautiful because I
know that's never a word you would call
yourself I look into your eyes and I see
the light and hope of myself in this
photo you're just about to turn 20
posing outside the television station
where you were recently hired as a
reporter you look calm you look happy
but I know how scared you are if I could
say anything to you
it would be relax it's gonna be okay
girl you just watched two amazing clips
from Oprah Winfrey take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]